When it comes to retail shopping,
statistically there is no day more
harmful to your physical wellbeing than
black Friday.
It's a day that can even be fatal.
In 2008 customers broke down the doors
at a Walmart in valley stream,
New York and an employee was killed in
the ensuing stampede.
Since then,
the occupational safety and Health
Administration or Osha has issued safety
guidelines for stores wanting to avoid a
similar incident and why do people go so
crazy on black Friday?
It's the deals of course,
the deals,
the opportunity to get a 32 inch plasma
TV for $179.
The chance to finish all your Christmas
shopping in one go.
The super big huge black promises of
such Gargantuan savings have
traditionally made black Friday the most
profitable shopping day of the year.
Indeed a number of businesses that
operate at a financial loss between
January and November,
one smart read in ledger books report
sales during the holiday season that
make the entire year profitable.
Profits by the way,
are written in black ink,
hence black Friday.
I'm about but but,
but the only problem is both the name
and the savings of black Friday aren't
exactly what they see.
Let me explain.
The first instances of the term black
Friday actually have nothing to do with
accounting jargon,
but with a newsletter from the
Philadelphia police department in the 19
sixties.
Lamenting the huge crowds,
traffic jams in general chaos on the day
after thanksgiving.
It was not a term of endearment for
Philly.
Cops knocked by a long shot despite
efforts to change the name to big
Friday,
the term stuck so it was left to
marketing executives to put a positive
spin on the whole thing and that's how
you get the black ink thier and indeed
like the name,
the promise savings of black Friday are
largely an illusion as well and
illusion,
carefully designed for you the customer
to act as irrationally and stupidly as
possible.
Big Box stores like Walmart and target
and best buy.
Don't put everything out for sale on
black Friday.
Instead,
they put out select items as lost
leaders.
Product sold at or close to a loss for
the company to get you in the door.
And amongst everything else,
they're still selling at a high margin.
You've got the TV,
but now you need the normally priced
wall mount,
the normally priced Hcmi cables and the
normally priced Roku.
Actually,
when you look again,
you see that the Roku though normally
priced comes with a $40 rebate,
which you can get back in two months.
Not Bad,
except for about 60 percent of rebates
never get fulfilled because people just
forget or they fail to comply with all
the print requirements they didn't read
when rushing around,
best buy in a friends.
Indeed,
retailers know exactly what it's like to
be in a hectic shopping environment and
they exploited it to the extreme.
They know that rebates feel good,
but people forget.
They know that warranty is may seem like
peace of mind and the checkout lane,
but actually fuel a 15 billion industry
of pure profit,
pure profit.
It feels so good.
They know that we shopped by means of
rationalization and justification that
by putting a super expensive item next
to a normally price one will increase
the sales of the latter because we don't
see price,
we see price different.
They know everything that this article
by economic researchers proved with the
help of Mri scans that we are not
rational actors when we shop,
but that the image of a deal lights up
our brain with pleasure like a Christmas
tree and that we choose between that
pleasure and the pain of spending when
deciding on a purchase.
Retailers do everything they can to
remove the immediate pain of spending,
hence rebates in store,
credit cards,
installment plans and the like,
but it's these things often riddled with
hidden fees and Hula hoops that ended up
killing and eclipsing the savings you
thought you were getting in the first
place.
As Derek Thompson writes in the
Atlantic,
the first and last rule of prices is
that nobody knows what anything is
really worth.
Shoppers are guided by shallow clues.
This is cheaper than that and latent
emotions.
It just feels like a good deal rather
than knowledge and deliberate thinking,
but this isn't just the case for black
Friday and increasingly anachronistic
term.
In a world of Cyber Mondays and
Thursdays where Santa is an employee of
Ford and Chevy and Mercedes-benz.
It's true the whole year round,
perhaps in this case the black ink
theory is worth keeping in mind.
It's the retailers that go into the
black on black Friday,
not the customers think of it that way
and it's easier to see that despite
every single ad saying otherwise the day
was never really about you.
It's about them
black.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching and happy
thanksgiving.
There is so much more to say about black
Friday,
particularly how it relates to economic
inequality in our country.
I didn't get into that,
but if you want to read more about it,
you can find that in the description
this thanksgiving.
I am grateful to you,
all of you.
Thank you so much for watching and
engaging all the comments on last week's
video about sexism or amazing,
incredibly thought out and I'm so glad I
got to have the conversation with you
and comments.
That's where it's always happening.
So I'm in comments and you can comment
and I will respond to you.
Make sure to follow me on twitter if you
haven't already.
A lot of you guys did last week.
Thank you for that and I will see you
next time.
That's my commercial voice.
You can find my resume for voiceover
work in the description.
I have no resume.